when you first joined the division what
were you expecting I'm sure they told
you about the sacrifices you'd make
things you might have to do one day but
none of us could have ever predicted
this
now if there's any chance of putting the
pieces of our city back together then
this is all up to you
when we first arrived this place was
destroyed but over time we can make it
our home
from here we launch countless missions
across the city in search of others
doctors former cops engineers people who
can help us rebuild the world
out there you'll need all your training
and equipment with every battle one
you'll become stronger
Oh
with every challenge met you will gain
power
spend enough time on your own and you'll
understand the truth you will die alone
if we don't stand together
other agents have set up safe houses
throughout the city you'll need to team
up with them and work together we have
to rely on each other's strengths to
save what remains and give New York a
fighting chance that's something we
thought was lost hope we need to work
together and combine our skills
we each have a role to play in this
fight
you are here for a reason
make no mistake we are taking this city
back
and on your journey you will find a
place beyond those walls a dark zone
where greed and fear corrupts and no one
can be trusted
this fight is only the beginning